alright hi guys i'm leonard law I'm one
of the product managers at Google that I
helps take care of our enterprise
strategy the reason I love working with
Google Cloud is seeing companies that
are driving innovation and business
transformation in their firms but I have
to be honest when I think of agriculture
and clouds I usually think about rain
not technology but that's why you know
sometimes innovation comes from
surprising places and that's why its my
incredible pleasure today to introduce
you to teddy boo Kelly from land o lakes
thank you thank you very much and thank
you for coming to the session I really
appreciate it i'm a really excited to
tell our story and some of the things
we've done here I lead IT for one of the
divisions within win fear within land o
lakes I'll talk a little bit about that
and then Joey jablonski from cloud
technology partners here to tell us
about the the journey that helped us
along the way so with that what are we
going to talk about today and I'm
actually going to read this because I
don't want to screw it up I tried to
memorize it and I was kind of forgetting
so by 2050 the world's exploding demand
will require farms to feed upwards of 10
billion people global leader in
precision agriculture land o'lakes uses
a novel application of cloud scale
computing alex to revolutionize modern
farming to produce more corn of your
acres today compared to 50 years ago
what does that mean that means is I get
to do things like when I was a kid you
know what do you want to do when you
grow up I want to solve world hunger and
and some of the things I'm able to do
now is actually do that and I get to do
that using cloud which is really really
exciting so first of all who here has
heard of land o'lakes awesome most hands
if you haven't seen me later have
packets of butter for you well thank you
right it's all I gave you one clue
butter what else do we make anybody have
any ideas what was that cat food oh yeah
that's ocarina so one of the names under
land o lakes as a Purina and so we made
animal feed and actually not quite cat
food because cat and dog is owned by
nestle but every other animal so think
of farm animals cattle chickens horses
and all that we have feed for that and
then the largest division within land o
lakes that most people don't know about
is actually our crop inputs business
under the name Winfield and that's what
we'll talk a little bit about today is
what Winfield does and who we are and
then how we've kind of taken technology
sort of to the next level and really
what we do as a crop input distributors
we buy seed crop protection plant
nutrition products from big manufactures
and then sell them to our customers who
are our owners and those customers in
turn sell them to growers so we work
closely on AG fields with a lot of with
a lot of agronomist and with a lot of
farmers trying to help them solve
different problems now one of the big
things for us is because of you know you
kind of talk about okay so you have
butter you have crop inputs you have
animal feed how does that all it's kind
of a weird holding company and actually
it's not it's actually carefully put
together because our owners are again
like dairy producers and AG providers
and really one of the things that gives
us the abilities to look at the whole
food chain so I'll give you an example
we sell seed or we also manufacture some
seed so you think about we put that
stuff in the ground it grows and let's
say for example that's corn silage or
alpha alpha which our crops those are
then fed to animals take example cows so
we feed the cows control the formulation
and then from those cows milk is
produced we buy that milk back from the
dairy producers we make butter cheese
milk etc and that gets up in the grocery
stores that you guys consume so one of
these we get to see the end end from the
time something was first created all the
way down to you guys consuming it in the
stores and that becomes a lot of fun
because it to see all the opportunities
risks and challenges within that value
chain so what are some of those
challenges right so one of the things we
see clearly is that by 2050 the world
population which is that seven billion
now is going to go to 9.2 billion and
actually the latest numbers would say
that you were going to go up to ten
point four billion so that's interesting
so we got to feed more people now the
other thing is also in a lot of the
developing countries the they're getting
better and better so the middle class is
rising because the middle class is
rising their diets change and so they
want you no more protein in their diet
etc so that what really that leads to is
that you know seventy percent more food
production that what we have today
right so okay you go that's kind of
interesting good good statistic at a
high level but here's that here's the
other side which is the challenge only
twelve percent of the land between now
and 2050 is arable actually no that's
not correct it's five percent twelve
percent is arable period five percent
because you know you have large
investments you have areas that don't
have water you have to put big
irrigation systems in place a lot of
infrastructure investments that don't
make sense yet so you can only kind of
farm where you can and so that is only
five percent and by the way agriculture
is also one of the most water intensive
industries of a lout there and we
require more water than anything else
out there is one of the oldest
industries and that's in water is key to
that so we would you know we need forty
percent more water than we actually have
today so that becomes a challenge so
really what do we get to at the end of
the day we need to produce more food but
we have less resources to do it so now
the nightie that's not that's not
uncommon or unheard of challenge do more
with less but in agriculture where you
get to plant the crop once you wait a
whole year and it girls again the idea
is okay what do you want me to do there
how does that how does that happen how
can we make that happen now the good
news is this is where I T kicks in this
is where technology really makes a
difference so what you see on this chart
is sort of the evolution of Agriculture
over time so on the x-axis you have the
years you know from the 1900s all the
way till the 20 50 or 20 60 mark and
there's been some revolutions along the
way so the mechanic ization was the
first revolution that sort of the
tractors attractions got smarter right
they started to do more and more things
and actually today some of these
tractors and combines drive themselves
so the guy actually sitting in the cab
is look watching Netflix if he's you
know not on top of his game if he's on
top of his game he's watching crop
prices and making business decisions but
it's very much automated then you had
the biotech revolution that started
about the 1950s and so all of a sudden
the seeds you put in the ground they
started you know the technology went
into it and a lot of it could produce
more with what you had and that's still
what's fueling agriculture today however
this next revolution is really going to
come from technology and what do I mean
by that so you take the largest crop in
the United States today which is corn
and we produce about the on average 170
bushels per acre I know for for those of
you not a nag that doesn't make a lot of
sense and I was told not to go into
agronomy too much but I have to a little
bit for you to get it so 170 bushels an
acre just think it as a number if we
were to increase production from 170
bushels an acre to 180 bushels an acre
that's a 10 bushel increase that's the
same as creating five million virtual
acres right so essentially here's the
idea that hey we can produce production
just a little bit you can actually
produce more with what you already have
and by the way if you control those
inputs you could actually keep the
inputs the same and still produce more
right now here's another interesting
statistic for you guys the highest
recorded yield for corn in the United
States was actually happened last year
at 530 bushels an acre right so in a
field right not in a greenhouse or lab
controlled actually that potentially go
up to a thousand but in a given field
somebody is actually able to achieve 530
bushels an acre so really if you go from
the average of 170 and the high end is
530 you're like well how does that
happen right well if you can make
agriculture today still intuition driven
I do it the way my dad did it maybe I
disagreed over the few things i'm going
to make those changes but essentially
it's more of a field still an art but
you start bringing data-driven facts to
these farmers that say hey use this
technology and use some crop modeling
use some scouting use some drone imagery
for it for that matter you can kind of
see what's happened on your large field
so i'm not talking about a small field
but like a hundred acre field and then
because you can make better decisions
now you can achieve this this is this
high range you can get 2 i'll give you
just an example this is one of the tools
we use today and what you see here is so
what we do is we take satellite imagery
so we take an image you know and it's
got to be clear with notes with no
clouds in the way but if we're able to
achieve that then the reflection off the
light of a plant we can it's different
for a healthy plant it reflects
differently than an unhealthy plant what
we do is we take a let that light
reflection we assign it a score let's
say a 10 like if it's good and two if
it's bad and then you take a color like
dark green for the good and red for the
two and essentially now you can create
like a geospatial algorithm with a file
on top of it that shows you how the
field is performing nobody's ever
stepped foot on that field so you can
see here is in zone number one that's a
that's a hard area you can see there
that we are Li have anything growing in
that spot makes sense right that
probably was a score of zero and then in
number four or number two which was the
dark green you can barely see that wind
field sign in there which means that
crops doing really well so now the
sudden you sort of have this idea of
like okay i can understand where the
crop is struggling and maybe i need to
do something there or the crop is doing
well so that's one decision you can make
off of this another decision could be
okay next year when i plant i know that
area number two and number three really
are high yielding so what I want to do
there is maybe I'll push the population
which means i'll put more seeds into the
ground and the specific spots and if i
do that i can yield more than i do if i
put the same amount in zone number one
it's called a variable rate planting so
all of a sudden with the same amount of
inputs that you had before you're
actually able to produce more alright so
this is a type of technology we're
getting into today a lot of fun very
very exciting but I get to go from this
intuition art down it's a little bit of
a science which is which is which is
pretty exciting and another thing here
to note for example is you know we
talked a little bit about in as
agriculture using technology and I was
talking to one of our presidents and
hour division i was trying to splain him
what I OT was right it's like IOT what
is that Internet of Things he's like
kind of just said the same thing again
I'm not really sure what that means so
I'm like okay so you have these sensors
that you can put in devices or machines
that really weren't doing anything
before they're dumb devices now you're
putting something in there that starts
talking and all of a sudden this device
has a voice it start to tell you what
it's doing you collect this with a whole
bunch of other devices you run some
analytics on top of that and by the way
now you have some great insights he's
like oh wow like we do that in
agriculture with the new stuff we're
doing right each plant is the thing like
an Internet of Things so if you think
about it an agriculture we didn't even
think about it before but we're actually
doing these type of things we're
internet a thing it's not necessarily a
sensor in something it could just be the
thing itself is actually telling you hey
I'm happy and healthy or I'm sick and
I'm not doing well so kind of
interesting stuff so how does cloud fit
into all this right well here's the
here's a decision so all these great
tools are coming to the market we have
one our competitors have some a lot of
pry apart
in the market are really helping us put
a lot of cool tools together but what's
happening these tools don't talk to each
other a lot of these are geospatial
files are very big they're very complex
you know you have prescriptions you have
tissue samples you have scouting reports
and the ideas for one tool to be really
effective it needs information from
another tool and yes we could create a
connection between the two but some of
this information is actually common to
many of these tools and what we want to
do is tell the farmer here go use these
three things when the when your crop is
growing and you know you'll get to from
that 170 bushels to 200 but he's like
well you know using three is going to be
really complicated i have a barrier to
use it to begin with then i have to
re-enter stuff three times that doesn't
work so that's when we came to ideas we
need some sort of centralized cloud
solution we need something that's going
to collect information from different
tools right so you see our 7 tool up
there on the on the left and we're going
to put some boundaries and prescriptions
from there into this centralized place
and from the centralized place we're
going to then give that information to
another tool so this was the concept
that we came up with and said this is a
really neat idea and by the way should
live in the cloud and makes sense
because these files get humongous and we
have 300,000 farmers in the United
States so this is going to get bigger
and bigger and so that's what idea of
like maybe we need to look at this and
maybe we need to look at a cloud
solution concept came into play and so
we reached out and we looked at you know
the various cloud solutions available
out there and you know one of the things
we found that gcp really offered was
like really kind of fit our needs for
the things we're looking for with the
geospatial needs with some of the newer
technologies that we were embarking on
this seemed to be a really good fit and
google also turned us to one of their
partners that could help us in the space
and this is where cloud technology
partners came in and they really had
helped us figure out how we put this in
from how you put this infrastructure in
place so that we could really enable our
tools and enable the farmers to make a
better decision so I'll turn it over to
Joey here and he'll tell you kind of
talk you through that they told us you
know told me to keep the agronomy to
minimum so hopefully I did that but he's
going to go more into the technical
infrastructure and how we built the
solution great thanks teddy
so it's teddy mentioned i work for cloud
technology partners we got the privilege
of spending almost an entire year
working very closely with the team at
land o lakes as part of the wind field
group building out data silo when we
first started with data silo we had a
million ideas we sat down with the
agronomists across land o'lakes we sat
down with agronomist from their partner
retailers and what we knew was that we
had a million features that we wanted to
build we knew that we had a problem we
wanted to solve around integrating data
from a variety of different sources and
we knew that we wanted to use the latest
and greatest in modern technologies so
we started with an assessment of the
cloud vendors that are out there we
settled on the Google platform as the
capability that gave us the fastest time
to market they're able to iterate very
very quickly in what we were developing
we were able to try new technologies
without having to build servers without
having to put him in the data center
because of Google's portfolio we were
able to try different things bigquery
cloud sequel data store and use the
technologies that made the best sense
for us from a development perspective
from a feature perspective and also from
a geospatial perspective everything we
did in data silo is spatial in nature so
being able to leverage Google Maps being
able to leverage some of the expertise
that Google brought really gave us an
advantage that allowed us to get this
application developed and tested quickly
so what is data silo at the end of the
day data silo is going to give us four
sets of capabilities the ability to
store information from disparate sources
the ability to share that information to
be able to allow farmers to give access
to their data to other people to be able
to search this information be able to
look at data by growing season by
location by address by spatial point and
most importantly be able to control this
data being able to control who has
access to it what systems the data is
fed to automatically when we first
started dating I lo our focal point was
very much internal systems there at land
o lakes and systems that the farmers
leveraged tools like our 74 building
crop prescriptions essentially defining
how many
I'm going to plant / give an acre tools
like Scout crow that give us the ability
to scout a field and take images and
samples and then tools like nutria
solutions that are laboratory management
capabilities that show us test results
and sample information data silo is
initially built to bring these together
but most importantly to connect to the
rest of the ecosystem that's being built
within the agriculture space companies
like Monsanto companies like John Deere
that are also putting data online prior
to tools like data silo prior to some of
these integrations that we built
literally the method for moving data
around in the agriculture space is USB
drives it was not uncommon for someone
to download a file on their computer
onto a USB Drive give it to a retailer
who then plugs it into a monitor on
their tractor to go use that data and
then do the reverse download the as
planted information from the monitor put
it back onto the USB drive snail mail it
back to somebody else data silos meant
to solve that problems we're not moving
USB drives anymore one of the key
elements though with data silo that we
wanted to focus on from early on is
access to information and privacy so
there's certain information that farmers
are extremely sensitive to keeping
confidential and not sharing with a
wider audience yield information is that
growers don't want to share how
successful their fields are they have
their own patterns and practices that
they use to get that level of efficiency
they don't want to share that
information very widely there's also in
like any industry legal rules
information about plots of land GIS
coordinates that make them up are
protected information that need to be
defended properly so when we build data
silo we built it from the ground up with
an access control infrastructure that
allows us to ensure that the owner of
that data the grower the operator of
that field can control exactly who sees
their data when they can audit that
access and most importantly they can
revoke that access and control it
so I want to talk a little bit about the
development timeline of data silo we
learned a lot as we went into this
process and we went into it with one key
assumption was that we don't know what
we're doing here this is the first of
its kind application in the market so
let's not try to invent things that are
too far along without getting market
validation without getting experts to it
to validate what we're doing so we
started this project I actually remember
the the kickoff of this project was on
my birthday of last year so I will
remember that day well got to spend it
with with a new client so we started the
project of a variety of discovery
workshops so we sat down with about 20
people from across land o'lakes from
across partners and retailers of theirs
and we just did brainstorming sessions
writing out every possible idea about
features usability drawing out potential
you is on the board we then moved into
designing our data model so one of the
challenges that we ran into early was
that we're integrating data from a
variety of different systems some of her
file based some of our relational
database based but most importantly no
single person had ever done design
across all of them so there was no clean
mapping of data between those systems so
we started with building a data model
that would allow us to ingest data from
source systems and put it into a
standard data model that would then
allow us to evolve over time and build
standardized api's standardized
workflows and then we built the data
silo one of our one of our real powerful
proof points on data silo was one of the
key features that we wanted to
demonstrate to the agronomists was
visual display of field boundaries so
essentially lines that designate where a
field is in a certain a certain area
from a development perspective not an
extremely complicated thing to do
there's there's libraries out there that
do it Google Maps provide provides
functionality but being able to do this
with live data that came out of other
land o'lakes systems was a very
important step because of the file
format challenges that first feature
that we built we were able to
demonstrate at the end of
second week so essentially our first
sprint as part of the project this
really shows the power of being able to
empower our developers we weren't
focused on deploying servers we won't
focused on networking problems we're
focused on writing code deploying in an
app engine and then testing it but most
importantly not testing it from a
developer perspective only but letting
our agronomist the end consumers of this
application tested as well we did a
security assessment early on in the
project we brought in the security team
from land o lakes brought in an expert
from my team to really make sure that
the model that we built was defendable
and that the data was going to be
protected the way our growers would be
comfortable with it and then finally
showing these boundaries that I talked
about the key here is that we learned a
very important lesson around April of
this project and made a very fundamental
shift we started this project with a
very file-based mindset how can we share
files how can we control access to files
the reason we did that is because we
were coming from the agronomist
perspective the way they interacted was
they move files around they put them on
a USB Drive they emailed him to people
from a development perspective this
became very difficult when you get data
in various file formats the quality is
poor people muck with the extensions
because of their virus protection files
are hard to parse particularly when
they're shape files because there are a
variety of different standards in the
industry that are used so this file
centric approach caused us a lot of
problems in the development cycle we
were running into data quality issues
running into performance problems so we
step back a little bit and said okay
let's stop looking at it from a file
perspective do growers really need files
and what they do and it occurred to us
that they don't at the end of the day
the growers need to control information
about their fields they need to control
prescriptions as planted information GIS
information so we threw out all of that
file based approach that we took with
the application and really switch to a
completely GIS or a spatial based
application
this was actually really good this
allowed us to simplify our data model
literally about half of our tables and
relationships in our data model
completely went away as we went to the
spatial approach because we no longer
had to build relationships in the
database we were able to infer them
spatially simplified our database we
didn't move database platforms as part
of this change we went to a database
that supported a lot more GIS capability
than the initial one we started with and
then finally building a lot more you I
capabilities one of the other challenges
we had learned as we started to do it
err ative demos after every sprint was
that we were getting a lot of feedback
particularly from Teddy and some of his
peers that the rendering on the screen
wasn't proper that elements weren't
showing up on the screen and it finally
occurred to us that we were doing all of
our development on a desktop we were
assuming the retailer's were going to be
using a desktop interface as well and it
turns out people like Teddy don't even
own desktops they do everything from
their phone so he made a very drastic
change in the development cycle here and
moved to a completely mobile first
development cycle with the desktop
interface is coming as a secondary
testing and secondary development this
enrichment of the UI a lot of the
retailer's gave us very positive
feedback because anyone in the field is
first going to be on a tablet or a phone
and much later on they'll be on a full
desktop or a laptop this second phase
the project made April we started
building a lot of our api's as well so
instead of moving files between systems
we got to a very programmatic approach
we were able to allow API connectivity
into data silo this became a very
important focal point because suddenly
systems like our seven nutri solutions
could connect automatically send a lot
of data to data silo and external
systems could query that information and
get it as well we did another security
assessment made a lot of fundamental
changes to the architecture in the
second phase so we moved did a secondary
security assessment and ultimately what
we ended up with was a very speacial
application the people could find
locations on a map and find all the data
associated with it they could query by
season they could query by type of crop
and
find information that way rather than
this file based approach with naming
conventions that become inconsistent
this got us a lot of very positive
feedback particularly from the retailers
that we were demoing and using as our
live audience we also replat form the
app we had actually started with Google
compute engine when we first started
building the app for speed as we moved a
lot more of these spatial capabilities
we actually made a choice to move to
Google compute as instead of CAP engine
mainly to give us a lot more GIS
functionality simplify things for the
developers so this file centric the
spatial centric was really a it was a
big light bulb I remember the day in the
conference room with an auth one of the
architects that works for teddy where we
finally realized that this was the
solution to all of our feedback we were
getting about a poor you i experience
about poor performance this file based
per approach was the the challenge let's
talk a little bit about the functional
architecture so we built out data silo
we really built three functional areas
that are unique in terms of what they
provide we built a presentation layer
and this presentation layer gives us
things like search capabilities the log
in all of our landing pages but also
more advanced features like
impersonation impersonation was critical
from a support perspective imagine
you're a you're a farmer you're working
out in Indiana and you've got a problem
with data silo it's not showing the data
you expect you call the Land O'Lakes
support line that individuals should be
able to impersonate that grower and
identify exactly what they're seeing so
we built those sorts of capabilities
that came from feedback from the
retailer community we also built our
access layer so the AP is that we built
built our data transformations but most
importantly we focused on compliance
with industry standards so whatta is an
agriculture standards body that's
focusing on data exchange trying to
drive some standards for how these
organizations work together and then
finally we built our data layer so our
database plus are associated
functionality around how we store things
like tissue samples like prescriptions
so from a from a logical architecture
the application was built to be highly
scalable but within reason so Teddy
mentioned earlier that there's about
300,000 farmers here in the United
States that's good actually so we never
had to build an application for a
million users we're never going to have
a million simultaneous users on data
silo so we built things with
technologies that were proven around
that idea so some of the technologies
that we built data silo people will look
at and say well those are you know but
we're using those five years ago and
it's true we were and they work so we
didn't want to over complicate the issue
for a couple of reasons one finding
software engineers for extremely modern
languages is much more difficult than
for proven languages like PHP like Java
so we went with technologies that were
proven we also went with a database
model that provide us highly scalability
because the reality is it's a very read
intensive environment we're really not
writing that much data in the grand
scheme of things so we used a more
traditional database model with
read-only slaves to give us scalability
so I mentioned earlier about our data
model and one of the areas we were able
to hugely simplify data silos when we
move to a geospatial approach rather
than a file approach what this allowed
us to do was instead of building
relationships in a database between
things like fertilizer prescriptions and
a field a field in a farm a farm and a
grower we're able to infer that
information because a seed prescription
or a fertilizer prescription have a
spatial location our field has a
boundary so identifying whether that
point fits in the boundary becomes a
mathematical calculation rather than
hard relationships in the database this
also became important some of the early
feedback we got from retailers was well
I want to upload a feel of a crop
prescription but I haven't defined my
field yet I haven't built in the data
silo so by the spatial nature were
essentially able to go take all of our
data throw it into data silo and then
identify
how it's related to one another and then
as time goes on you can add additional
fields you can add additional views on
it one of the key things to keep in mind
in the agriculture space is that a field
is not a lifelong concept a feel tends
to be something that's memorable to the
grower you know Joe's field Bob's farm
sometimes there's an address associated
with maybe what road it's on the corner
of the intersection of what highways but
most importantly that field the polygon
the spatial information for it changes
every single growing season because you
may have taken out a tree that was in
the corner of the field the stream may
be running a little bit higher flow this
year than it was last year so that
information is constantly changing year
after year so as we built our data model
we tried to stay away from any
assumptions about relationships for
fields for the data associated with it
and let the grower choose those let them
decide how the data is related to one
another so this is a another
representation of the data model so at
the center what you'll see is that we
define resources and in data silo what
we defined was essentially anything as a
resource a prescription a field a
boundary tissue samples and soil samples
those resources then have access
controls that associate with them so we
have tables that define who can access
the data what they can do with it most
importantly we have an audit table so we
can identify who changed data win who
uploaded data win where it came from and
then of course all of our user
information the user information is
where we store things like defaults when
user logged in we actually had a concept
in the application called widgets that
when you log into the application
there's a widget that tells you how many
acres you have mapped in the system how
many prescriptions you have harvest
information so those sorts of defaults
as to what experience the user once when
they log in from a functional
perspective we had a variety of
technologies that we used at the top
tier so essentially presentation we use
bootstrap as our mobile and our
responsive framework supported by HTML
and
little bit of PHP all of our api's were
essentially endpoints that we exposed
and wrote in in PHP at the application
level we really built two functional
areas we built all of our business logic
and PHP it's easy to mock up it's fast
to develop easy too easy to redo if we
have to throw out sections of the code
but most importantly built our file
processing so one night if I'm I've
mentioned a lot is shapefiles
essentially a shapefile is a GIS
standard for how you exchange
information about a field or a bunch of
points well there's a certain type of
shape file you get an agriculture called
an as planted it as plants it
essentially defines how many seeds were
planted at what GIS locations in a field
well you imagine a field that's you know
even a few acres these files tend to
have millions and millions of points so
we wanted a very highly scalable
processing engine to bring in these
shape files to decompose them into
something that we can store in the
database in a meaningful way so we built
this Python file processors they can
bring all this data and process it and
ultimately we used the zend framework as
our our PHP framework to get us go and
quickly build technology quickly no the
other piece that we talked about quite a
bit was API I think you know over the
course of the the nine months to build
data silo we probably had about a
hundred and fifty hours of meetings on
API design and the struggle we had for
API design was that there's first off no
industry standards so there really
wasn't anything we could we could key
off of there are several industry bodies
that are there things like adapt
organizations like Oh adda but they're
not ratified yet so there are standards
that we could try to leverage to the
best of our ability but they're really
not finalized yet the other element is
that the API structure gets very
complicated as you start to look at all
the potential options so one of the
things that we did early on a data silos
we really kept a small focus we started
with connectivity to our seven so that
meant all we had to deal with was
prescriptions and then we started
talking to neutral
vision so then we could bring in tissue
and soil samples we took the same
approach with the api's so we built
api's to start with a small subset of
our data types and then increasing from
there so from a platform perspective
we've used a variety of technologies as
I mentioned we did start with App Engine
really really you know get going quickly
build technology ultimately we moved to
compute engine just because there were
some GIS capabilities that we needed
that we needed to install locally in a
full operating system and then we
leveraged Google's cloud storage quite a
bit the idea behind cloud storage was
that all of these files that were coming
inbound these shapefiles these other
exchange formats like CSVs we needed a
place to store them in their raw format
we weren't actually decomposing all the
files in their entirety in data silo we
only extracted the information we needed
to provide the user with the experience
that we were we were targeting for data
silent so we still ordered all of our
raw data any JSON objects that came in
as part of API connectivity we stored in
cloud storage as well so if we ever
needed to go back and recreate data
restructure the database we had the raw
information to go do that as we needed
the other power of the the platform that
we see longer term is as we add
additional data types one of the visions
for data silo long-term is to start
bringing in satellite imagery so that
people can enhance that with the
information stored in dat asylum so
tools like cloud storage will become
very valuable as we start to bring in
more and more tissue sample soil sample
as more sensors get used tools like
bigquery will become very powerful to be
able to connect to very quickly and
query large amounts of information that
is that is heavily read-only so talk a
little bit about our lessons learned the
cloud the cloud was good and there were
parts of it that were bad as well so it
was good from a flexibility perspective
we were able to build apps very very
quickly the struggle was there is a
learning curve for it you need to be
cognizant upfront that the way you do
operations the way you build your
environment the way you monitor
it is different so as part of the
project what we did is we sat down with
some of teddys peers that run the IT
operations side and spend time talking
with them about how they would operate a
system like this we didn't go into it
blind saying we build the application
and that it's perfect we realized that
we build it then we hand it off to an
operations team then they have to run
with it for the foreseeable future so we
sat down with those operations teams
early and made sure they had the
instrumentation they needed one of the
pieces that their operations team was
very sensitive to was availability of
the application so we actually
instrumented the application or a lot of
monitoring capabilities so they're
monitoring systems could connect to the
application in different ways and verify
that the file processor was working
independently from the UI which was
working independently from the business
logic on the back end so we instrumented
it for those operations folks the other
piece is understanding your user base
there's really two factors here first is
the scale comment that I made earlier if
you're not ever going to have a million
users don't design for a million users
you're just adding unnecessary
complexity we were lucky in that we had
a population of users that we knew and
we understood very well they're also a
group that we can plan very well the
thing about a growing season is we can
plan for it every single year we know
when the growing season is going to
start we know when people are going to
harvest so we can plan our computing
power what we need how many users are
going to come into these systems based
on that that one year cycle and then use
technologies that your team is
comfortable with one of the biggest
struggles I see in organizations is
shoehorning in technologies that the
development teams the operations teams
aren't comfortable with you're asking
for an organization that's first going
to push back but secondarily not going
to be as effective because they don't
have the technology depth one of the
reasons we chose the technologies we did
is because there are people at the land
o'lakes organization within their
development team that understand them
and can take that long term cycle of
adding additional features debugging
problems
so pick technologies that your company
your organization is comfortable with it
lowers that barrier to entry makes
people more comfortable with cloud as a
platform because they're not having to
learn as many new things the same time
but once you're on the cloud then it
gives you a lot more technology that you
can take advantage of once you're
comfortable teddy pass it back to you
for the last life yeah absolutely so you
kind of walk through a little bit of how
we solve this problem right and one of
the things as Joey was talking what's
interesting is the name data silo right
so if you know kind of listen to what he
said it was anything but a silo right
the idea is making more of a hub to move
information around but the one of the
things about adapting to your customers
silo makes a lot of sense in a farmer's
world because you're most imp runner or
your prized possession is your grain
that comes off your fields and that
grain stored in a silo so for them that
was the idea that you put it in a silo
and then that's where the information is
going to be now what you see here on the
chart is really you know this is a
little bit of land o'lakes a story a
little bit of stories you know kind of
an agonist as a whole and what you see
is you know guy have this chart and the
red line really represents the planted
acres and so over the years it's kind of
gone down a little bit depending on the
years in which farmers didn't make money
so they planted less two years where
they made money so it went up a little
bit but the ideas it hasn't changed over
the years however the crop production
has gone up right and so that's what
that the revolution on the on the on the
equipment revolution on the biotech and
really what we're hoping for is now is
that the technology is you're going to
be the next frontier really the software
development cloud IOT all the things we
talked about at this conference really
what's going to take us to the next
level of producing more with less it so
that story we have any want to continue
it you know really happy with you know
kind of the place where we are today and
I engage all of you to get familiar with
agriculture and some of the things we're
doing a technology there like I said the
opportunity is great right we talked
about that 170 bushel an acre average
all the way up there's a potential to
get to 550 really what's going to get us
there is is the is the adoption of new
technologies of kind of changing farming
from intuition to a data-driven
industry so with that I thank you for
your participation and I will take any
questions at this point no question
there
oh so the question was were there cloud
providers that we looked at as part of
this process yeah so we we did look
across the industry when we first kicked
off this project we we in a we had a
small set of requirements that we used
for that that vendor assessment first
and foremost was speed we wanted our
development team to focus on building an
application that we could demo we wanted
a provider that was scalable we wanted
one that we knew was going to be there
for the long run we also wanted a
provider that was flexible that had
diverse enough portfolio of technologies
that if we made the wrong technology
decision early we could pivot very
quickly that having to change providers
so we did look across the board of the
other public cloud providers did a
pretty detailed assessment and
ultimately settled on on Google as the
platte path forward yeah it was
interesting I think all that is when we
were doing that assessment and we had
you know CTP and with us the questions
were okay so we kind of get at a high
level you want to build something we
store some files maybe data not really
sure and then it was like yep that's
what we want to do can you tell us more
about it no that's about what we want to
do right so the idea was you know we had
to go through and ideas okay let's let's
start building something that can get us
within six weeks we can have a proof of
concept for you we work together on that
we learn and then we iterate from there
and that's really what what helped us
and I'd say we went through four or five
iterations before we got the point we
said yeah I think we think we got what
we need yep and it was an interesting
cycle we we did a traditional agile
development cycle we managed a backlog
we groomed it every couple of weeks we
did a sprint demo at the end of every
every two weeks and the folks in that
demo came from the agronomists at land
o'lakes individuals from the retailers
and ultimately what happened is there
were some features that came out of
those demos that the retailers me
agronomists like thumbs up those are
great let's keep iterating on those and
make those features better there were
other features where the agronomist took
one look at it and said yeah I know I
asked for it but I really don't need
that that feedback was invaluable we
were able to manage our time very
effectively we're able to focus in on
features that provided real value
for the geographical information systems
did you lose completely Google solutions
or something like ESRI or any other
solutions outside the Google yeah so for
Earth the GIS components we actually use
post GIS which is no source set of
libraries that run on top of postgres so
that was our GIS infrastructure as part
of data silo with in Land O'Lakes there
are other systems that are running the
ESRI toolkit a lot of the desktop folks
so a lot of the files that we were
receiving and the files that we were
producing to send data out needed to be
compliant with some of the ESRI
standards for you know view perspective
those types of things in your work out
so you talked a little bit about how you
built the clouds at the security
solution and some of the constraints but
i'm wondering teddy in terms of just
like adoption and earning the trust of
farmers putting what I imagine is really
really precious data to them and you
know other parts of your company and
kind of curious like how did that work
and maybe even for the application
overall yeah good question and then data
privacy and the whole trust thing is
interesting so farmers if you want to
find a conspiracy theorist go to any
farm those are those are the guys out to
everything is coming the government out
to get them all that good stuff right
now the one thing is I will say is our
our system our company the way it's
built as a co-op so actually the growers
the farmers own the retail locations in
the retail location on us so that kind
of element of trust is already there and
so what's interesting is you know we
would go and you know we as Winfield
land o lakes will try to pitch this
information to a set of growers to kind
of see what they felt like and they're
like I don't know about putting my stuff
in something like that etcetera etcetera
and then but usual we went there we
would go with retail the guy was our
customer and there and he's like oh no
you don't have to worry about that
that's the type of stuff I would do for
you right you were to give me your USB
drives a whole bunch of them in the
office at my desk drawer so it's a
better way for me to manage this so then
you and I can have a conversation about
what we planned next year oh that's fine
I mean that's how that conversation
would go so so these retail agronomists
that are kind of local I mean some of
them you know they go to each other's
weddings their kids play together etc so
they have that level of trust so it was
very important for us to get those guys
on board which is why when we were doing
a lot of this print demos etc we had
those guys kind of give us feedback
right away to make sure that that
adoption was there and actually it turns
out this was actually a need in the
industry a lot of people you know
originally my kind intent was you know
want to move files around so we could
use these tools and that's truly the
ultimate goal but people you just felt
better that like if I have a place where
I can put my data and it's secure and
it's you know it's not like in a USB
Drive or my computer that you know
doesn't turn on anymore because has a
virus this was a lot better solution and
so that was kind of a byproduct of it as
well
I understand the impact that this kind
of data silo could have with the
upstream supply chain and the farmers
but can you talk a little bit more about
what you saw as the business impact with
retailers yeah so for retailers the big
deal was so you know I would say is our
first our challenge at gene adoption was
with that with the retail community at
first right because it was like well
should I go with you guys or not so we
had a natural hedge there a little bit
because it's cooperative structure right
so they were you know they're willing to
kind of work with us and they're already
part of owning land o lakes so if their
general manager voted against it would
certainly something we wouldn't do but
as far as what helped them at the end of
the day's these guys talked to the
farmers throughout the year so they
start out with in the spring or say in
the fall they talk about what are we
going to do next year right what are we
going to plant which see do you want me
to order what kind of how we're going to
protect the field going forward because
next year looks like it's going to be a
wet year etc etc right then then the
conversation moves into the spring rat
chat you plant the stuff into the field
because the seed arrived and then we get
into the crops grow when what kind of
decisions do we make now do we apply
more nitrogen or not you know how do we
which areas and all that kind of stuff
so it's it's a kind of a mess today a
little bit right so it's almost like
you're running by with the seeds you
know like would do everything on fire
right like it's like one thing and then
the other so with these tools they're
able to better manage that relationship
with the grower right so it was the idea
was ok so this tool is going to help you
this time of the year and we're going to
tell you how that works this next time
this how you can have the conversation
then you look like satellite imagery and
that's how you go have a conversation
about which area is struggling so with
the fact that we said you could use
these four or five tools now to help
that grow or have a discussion it's
going to enable your business even
further because once they have a better
idea of how to make these decisions then
then in the end the tools are connected
to each other you have a better you know
sort of there was no reason that grower
is going to go somewhere else right so
they stick with you and that resonated a
lot with them because even if they're
our friends at the end of the day if I
got something else or a better story
from another guy can go over there so it
showed them a way to say this is how you
keep your your strong relationship even
stronger than it is today hopefully that
answers your question
yeah alright with that I'd like to just
wrap up the session thank you very much
Teddy Joey for your talk and thank you
all for coming thank you
you